la venue d'anne forte à toronto au porte
encore les marques de la fusillade de
juliette 2018 qui a fait deux morts et
13 blessés
c'est ici qu'est mort l'ami de north a
mis la métropole canadienne est frappé
depuis plusieurs mois par une hausse de
la violence par armes à feu
pour répondre à la crise justin trudeau
promet une série de mesures on va bannir
les armes d'assaut et travailler avec
les provinces pour permettre aux
municipalités de restreindre les armes
de poing libéraux s'engagent à mettre
sur pied un programme de rachat pour les
propriétaires d'armes militaires
justin trudeau promet aussi de ne pas
créer un nouveau registre des armes à
feu
il y à des politiciens conservateurs qui
veulent affaiblir le contrôle des armes
à feu
les libéraux nous on veut resserrer le
contrôle des armes à feu
le chef conservateur croit qu interdire
certains types d'armes ne réglera pas le
problème nous écoutons les experts que
c'est mieux utiliser les ressources
policières a comme à lutter contre les
gangs de route et les armes à feu et les
vents pour sa part le chef du npd
partage la position libérale mais il
accuse justin trudeau de s'être traîné
les pieds
c'est quelque chose que j'ai exigé le
gouvernement fédéral monsieur joe 2 de
faire il y a plus de nan parce que il
faut donner cette pouvoirs aux
municipalités qui le veut le maire de
toronto john tory rappelle que liv il
voulait pouvoir interdire les armes de
poing je crois que national
le groupe poly se souvient salut
l'interdiction des armes d'assaut et
déplore que les armes de poing seront
encore disponibles dans certaines villes
contrairement à ce que les libéraux
avaient promis en 2015
décevant c'est pas une bonne idée de
transférer le fardeau de ce combat parce
que c'est un combat aux municipalités
dit morin du collectif touche contre un
registre québécois des armes à feu n'est
pas du tout d'accord on s'attaque
directement aux tireurs sportifs c'est
près d'un million propriétaires d'armes
à feu au canada qui font du tir sportif
qui font du tir à la cible
avec cette promesse des libéraux
espéraient recadrer leurs messages et
tourner la page sur la contreverse du
blind faith et justin trudeau s'est fait
interpeller dans les rues de toronto par
dépasse 1 et encore dû répondre à
plusieurs questions sur le sujet il
suffit de vincent foisy radio canada
toronto